ils sont les derniers employés de
chapelle darblay près de rouen la seule
usine en france à produire du papier 100
% recyclé
son propriétaire le géant finlandais upm
la mise en vente en septembre 2019
les papes chap veulent éviter le
licenciement de 230 salariés
le démantèlement de l'usiné dont
l'activité a commencé à décliner il y a
cinq ans alors ils ont tout tenté pour
trouver un repreneur manifestations
blocages de lusine en janvier
mobilisation des politiques
le maire de rouyn une cinquantaine
d'élus normands ont écrit au premier
ministre en juin
même le ministre de l'économie bruno le
maire avait promis de les aider nous
pouvons retrouver une solution de
reprise pour la chapelle darblay une
reprise est possible et nous continuons
à y travailler
malheureusement leurs efforts ont pour
le moment été vains aujourd'hui le site
dispose vraiment d'atouts pour un
repreneur on est sur un site qu'à une
chaudière biomasse est une station
d'épuration qu'à un centre de tri est
gavé ligue de désencrage bien sûr tu ne
me crois que ça fait plus d'un an après
l'annnonce du 10 septembre 2019 qu'on se
bat nous sommes toujours ici et bien sûr
pas résigné le site a des atouts et nous
allons bonne espérance qu il y ait des
solutions dans quelques heures avant sa
fermeture en juin dernier
chapelle darblay produisent et 250 mille
tonnes de papier journal par an
entièrement à partir de papier recyclé
cela correspondait au tri de plus de 20
millions de personnes
que vont devenir les cartons et papiers
usagés des français la demande en papier
journal a diminué mais il ya d'autres
débouchés
l'autre possibilité c'est dans la
production de pâtes marchande recyclé
pour une application sanitaires les
essuie-tout les mouchoirs
dans le cas de la transition écologique
la rénovation thermique thermique des
bâtiments
nous pouvons trouver pardon des
applications dans la production de
papier pour produire des panneaux de
watts pour isolation
les salariés espèrent trouver des appuis
politiques pour sauvegarder leur
entreprise on a eu plusieurs contacts
mieux quelques députés qui sont venus
nous voir qu'ils ont très bien compris
le sujet qui l'emporté c'est comme ça on
sait que aussi le l'histoire d'en
arriver aux oreilles non plus notre
combat et on a besoin
que maintenant l'état joue son rôle s'y
intéressent mais on a joué le nôtre sur
place à aux jo de l'or le nouveau maire
socialiste de rouen nicolas mayer
rossignol les soutiens depuis le début
estimant que cette fermeture est une
aberration environnementale étions faire
je cite on se retrouve à faire quoi va
brûler du papier à enfouir du papier
c'est complètement absurde
donc c'est une question d'emploi
évidemment pour le territoire mais ça va
bien au delà c'est un enjeu national
on peut pas dire d'un côté la france
d'après salon de l'écologie l'économie
circulaire et dans le même temps si
j'ose dire de fermer chapelle darblay et
on se bat au tir avec l'état ou essayer
de trouver des repreneurs possibles peut
pas tout dire mais il ya des déceptions
avec un certain nombre d'entreprises
ils sont intéressés par le site moi j'en
appelle au gouvernement
il vous aide au niveau de techniques les
tablettes haut niveau mais on a besoin
d'une parole politique fort pour parler
notamment à l'upm et aux repreneurs
potentiels selon les syndicats pour
sauver l'ensemble de l'usiné
il faudrait investir près de 100
millions d'euros le 15 janvier prochain
une commission industriels se réunira
avec le préfet de seine-maritime pour
faire le point sur les différentes
pistes de sauvegarde
il faudrait avant tout une réelle
volonté politique de bercy pour sauver
ce fleuron industriel de l'économie
circulaire